draußen since grad moment 34 grad und
ich steht drin und machen video läuft
würde ich mal sagen
damit ist congstar die abscheidung des
campus of directors club willkommen bei
anderen video und wie ihr ja bestimmt
von dem titel gelesen habt es geht heute
einfach mal darum wie jungs sind wenn
sie alleine sind und wie sie sind wenn
sie halt unter mädchen sind oder mit
mädchen zusammen ach ja und wenn ihr
nach dem video blog habt auch teil zwei
weil es gibt wirklich so viel dann lass
doch mal rum da würd mich freuen und
generell so wenn solche fällt einem
anderen hof ist super denn ich mache vor
allem aus diesem grund das video waren
wir andauernd die frage stellt warum
verstellen sich jungs oder warum wollen
sie mal so cool sein will sie mit
mädchen zusammen mit und ja warum ist
das halt so und deswegen will ich gar
nicht lange lagern es geht direkt mal
los mit punkt eins und punkt eins ist
eine haare sehen und so als wäre ich so
richtig brav so irgendwie finde ich auf
jeden fall ist punkt eins wir fangen
einfach mal ganz locker anzocken also so
zocken
aufregen aber das ist ein bisschen ich
mach mal kurz 1 leyser viel zu laut im
moment können wir uns ja gar nicht
unterhalb gespielt erst mal eine runde
bis ich sterbe dann kannst du spielen
hatte ich jedenfalls habe das video ist
umso knapp 8,4 der ball geht immer
weiter runter laufen aber das wird
richtig mehr war
sie ist jetzt haben sie mich scheiße
reagiert richtig verstehe auch gar nicht
diese jungs sie dabei so ausrasten wenn
sich mein passiert hat man ja heute
damit auch schon punkt 2 das ist
wirklich ein wichtiger punkt oder da
fällt mir immer wieder auf bei mir ist
es jetzt nicht so stark aber es gibt
jungs diese teil wenn ihr mit mädchen
zusammen immer so richtig so cool so und
das wollte ich euch mal an diesem
beispiel veranschaulichen
mit wem spreche ich beruhigt dich mal
ein bisschen ja kommandos herunter ich
habe doch schon so oft gesagt es tut mir
leid ja ne ist es tut mir wirklich leid
warum beleidigt du mich denn jetzt ich
beleidige dich doch auch nicht-christen
geld kein problem alles super genau
nein du brauchst dich mit deinen
freunden vorbeikommen und nein brauchst
du nicht nein
ja ich habe schon verstanden ist alles
super dann haben wir das erklärt ich
kein problem christel von mir bitte ins
netz ja das war jetzt nur gespielt war
so ein deutscher bin ich höre ich wie zu
hause
ja hallo
mit wem spreche ich konnte gar nicht du
schon wieder ohne schaltung
wie oft soll ich dir noch sagen du
kriegst das geld von mir nicht ja dann
komm doch her ist kein ding komm her du
weißt wo ich wohne ja du kannst auch
gerne fünfter
freunde mit ihm das ist mir scheißegal
ich meine guckt mich an und ich an
ja ich sage jetzt mal ein zuwachs hier
aufzutauchen lernst du mich von einer
ganz anderen seite kennen ja wir sehen
uns zu wir sehen uns glauben immer das
gleiche ich bin cool und punkt 3 und
zwar punkt drei mal ganz locker weg
essen fall einfach essen ist scheiße
ich hab da mal ein paar das natürlich
als erstes kann man durchaus ja ja ja
das tut mir leid ich habe ich geträumt
so was ich mit speziellen mal sehr
unangenehm weißt du ja und jetzt das
letzte das fällt mir oder das passiert
mir auch andauernd und zwar ich traue
mich nicht so mädchen zu sagen hier
kommen ich mache nur eben foto und so
für ins heim oder so sondern ich löst
das ein bisschen an das uns war so also
erstmal jungs halt unter sich und dann
halten wie ich das so mit den mädchen
dabei ist machtlos
nehmen wir das schon foto machen stimmt
was vergessen was soll ich machen
die speicherkarte von kann die zitzen
jetzt noch gar nicht du musst heute
mache ich noch heftiger bisher noch
bisschen noch mehr so gut wird kalter
butter solche installation direkt gut so
die haben dann können wir auch schon
gehen gerne schon mal vor unten raus
also ich komme sofort eine police jawohl
geil
leute ich hatte ja am anfang schon
gesagt falls überhaupt teil 2 und sodann
geht frauen nach oben würde mich freuen
als würde ich sagen ist aber alles
eingebildet auto mal in der video
beschreibung nicht vergessen noch nicht
zu fassen wir sehen uns dann nächste
woche nehmen wir sehen schon mittwoch
wieder auf jeden fall geht es hier noch
auf der rechten oberen seite weiter mit
wie man keinen jungen beeindruckt check
das auf jeden fall ab mich ansonsten
rein bis mittwoch 2